just go for it don't get stuck in your
head start with what you have be
sustainable study headline focused on
titles oh not working do it because you
want to find somebody you admire bring
value to people and share all of your
experience in your expertise with the
world what's up everyone what are we
doing today oh we're going to meet up
some youtubers so I wanted to give back
to my local community here in Toronto
and city and I set up a meetup group for
YouTube entrepreneurs who want to come
out and talk with me review their
channels meet each other hopefully get
some guidance and inspiration to build
their channels up and tonight is the
first event we're holding it at Channel
dance salsa we made it a potluck thing
and we'll see i'm super excited we'll
see how it goes Nina's coming along do
you get some great advice too so we got
to go get some food and then head over
the tds
hey I Milan from audio insurgency and my
one tip for a YouTube channel is be
sustainable leave enough energy behind
for the next YouTube video hi my name is
Bruce harbin and my one tip is to study
headlines the title you put on your
video really matters to catch interest
you can study Copyblogger for tips on
that have a good day
hi I'm Michael so easy and my tip for
your YouTube channel is that focused on
titles and tags don't put the title that
you want to put put the title that what
you would search if you were to find
that content so a lot of times you
actually want to like going to put the
title about your company your own
YouTube channel your own name but make
sure you put the title and tags that
people are going to search on youtube
good day hi i'm allison miller and I
guess my tip would be you know you have
an idea just go for if it's fun and
creative it's worth you know you have
nothing to lose but to try it hi my name
is Richard II gotta love and my channel
is about the powerful creating your own
YouTube channel on how to make it happen
and my tip for you is wherever you are
if you're thinking about setting up your
own YouTube channel don't get stuck in
your head just start where you are use
your webcam use just a little tiny
camera use a point-and-shoot use a pro
build a team whatever you want just get
started don't overthink it just get
started and have fun experiment fail
your way forward that's all I have to
say for you today and have an awesome
day
hi guys my name is Palestrina if you
guys are starting youtube you should be
true to yourself and do it because you
want to don't do it because you want to
become famous or anything my name is
Alex I'm with Toronto dance salsa so I
have a snapchat group that people are
following as you get started whatever
video you're making the most important
things you want to bring value to people
and you want have a bit of a direction
or a goal what is it that when you do
your video what are they taking away
from it should be one big thing and
that's how I think i can bring value to
people try that hi my name is mike i'm
the founder of the up and coming youtube
channel achievement Empire and my tip to
you guys all is that you should really
start YouTube channel so you can share
all of your experience and your
expertise with the world thank you
hello my name is MJ and my tip for you
is start with what you have and just do
it don't wait for any excuse just go
with what you're having and you'll
improve as you go along Thanks okay so
everyone has games please don't be
afraid to chase them yeah just before I
just don't let other people say you're
not worth it do whatever the hassle take
to reach you better a better version hi
everybody money's Tricia and I just want
to encourage everybody to go ahead and
take a chance and start a YouTube
channel find somebody you admire I mean
there are so many niches on YouTube and
there's so many great people that are
just doing amazing thing and a half huge
followers so pointedly the human Meyer
fight a few people that you admire
follow them find out what they're doing
right and that'll really inspire you to
just go ahead and get started it doesn't
have to be perfect to start I don't have
really good lighting I have a good
microphone but that's with it and you
know what I just took a chance and I
just started to put some things up there
and hopefully my goal is to get
something up there at least once a week
so hopefully you I encourage some of you
to go ahead and get started but that's
my advice mostly to myself right now and
that's my goal and yeah I hope to see
some view on YouTube
see you too all right it is almost
eleven o'clock everybody has left we are
cleaning up and when I say we it's not I
didn't really do anything it's me me
Vietnam nina de alex did all the cleanup
i was chatting i was chatting I'm blown
away by some of the talent in this city
it's crazy people who have production
quality better than mine and and have to
thousands of spiders it's insane now the
missus some other things that I think
hopefully they learned a lot there was a
lot of knowledge a lot of good energy
today when I did this I had no idea what
to expect you'll Nina asked me at the
start how many people are coming tonight
I said well plenty something people
signed up but I don't know how many
people watch to come and I didn't know
if this would be regular series just a
one-time thing and it was just kind of
chaos at the start and from that we got
some structure and organization and it
was it was a lot of fun people had a lot
of fun a lot of good ideas were
exchanged and I'm excited to see where
this meetup goes and also where all
these entrepreneurs go I want to do with
the channels I'm super proud of the city
super proud of what everybody's up to
and just feeling good feeling you know
heart full did a good good job tonight
and we're going to continue it and i'll
keep you guys posted with how we do so
thank you guys for watching nina hit it
up hit it up with the belief in the
background continue to believe I don't
see you soon look what's happening with
your hair look at that way look on the
side look huh here I like it here well
look what happened with my hair holy cow
gotta fix that